with the united kingdom leaving the
european union it's natural to wonder
what this means for the EU going forward
and there's really two different ways to
think about it good if you want to be
optimistic about the European project is
if the EU could actually be stronger
without the UK to understand how it
helps to look at the history of the EU
and the idea is to take this this
continent that you know is the cradle of
a wonderful civilization but has also
been the scene of some incredibly
destructive Wars of horrifico Attica
lines and make sure that kind of thing
can never happen again and the idea was
that if they unified the steel and pol
industries across national boundaries
they wouldn't be able to fight wars with
one another but the UK was never
completely on board they weren't one of
the six original countries to join up
they joined a little bit reluctantly
they didn't want to join the single
currency project and English people have
in a geographical sense often not felt
that they're even quote unquote part of
Europe so to an extent they've always
been the marginal member and if anyone's
gonna leave it would be them once the UK
is out the remaining countries might be
able to get some important things done
like crafting a common immigration and
foreign policy which the EU doesn't have
and trying to figure out a way to make
the common currency work better don't
have a common tax policy they don't have
a common welfare state it may be easier
for the countries that were meeting to
build sort of stronger institutions and
you may ultimately see a sort of a
stronger even though it's a smaller
that's the optimistic view another view
could be that we're looking at sort of
the beginning of the unraveling of the
whole thing you start pulling a thread
on the sweater and it's all gonna
collapse
you see polls from France and even
Germany the countries that at the very
heart of Europe showing that it's become
unpopular they don't feel ownership over
European politics it's a bunch of guys
sitting around in a Belgian City
negotiating deals and a language they
don't speak they don't have a spirit of
European
and a wheel like a deep emotional
European identity so the EU has a lot of
the attributes of a nation-state it has
a flag to have a national anthem but it
doesn't have any words if you feel that
a single Inu soccer team it will win the
World Cup every time but nobody looks
cheerful so a lot of how this turns out
in the end is gonna have to do with what
kind of deal the UK could reach with the
EU if the UK manages to get out but to
then still have a really favorable free
trade deal with the EU and really sort
of prosper that's gonna make it easier
for other countries to say well they
want out too every time a decision
happens that they don't like so there's
a there's a strong incentive to make
this messy to make it really as painful
as possible if you leaders manage to
exact a high price from the UK and
leaving that means that probably the
rest of the Union is not gonna break up